oh the po top 10 list am I really going
back to that well well yes but also no
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of Po spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
today I'm going to share with you the
names of 10 po Spinners whose work
really stuck out to me this past year
because I think you should check them
out too but before we dive into all that
I just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro ter light
toys spinballs and Ultra for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non-b business
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission so quick
context for nearly a decade I hosted a
regular feature on this channel called
the top 10 favorite po Spinners list
people would vote for their favorite po
Spinners by leaving a comment on a video
I posted earlier in December I'd tally
up how many mentions each artist got and
finally publish a video compilation
featuring the top 10 finishers on New
Year's Day this project was also really
controversial some Sami is encouraging
more competitive elements in the POI
community and or platforming people who
engaged in a variety of negative
behaviors and you know what a lot of the
criticisms were Justified so I retired
the list but I also have to admit that I
kind of miss learning about new artists
every year as well as potentially
introducing others out there to new
artists that they might enjoy so I'm
going to try something new this year and
share with you a purely subjective list
of my personal favorite po Spinners from
the past year and I'm going to invite
yall to share your favorites with me too
and so here are 10 po Spinners whose
work I really dug in the past year I
hope you dig them too coming in at
number 10 is Daniel skodak or melon man
he first came to my attention a couple
years ago by uploading a series of
buttery smooth videos on Gunslingers
that made me go back to the drawing
board and work more on my own since then
he pops up regularly with a variety of
fun Combos and tricks that just make my
jaw drop he has an effortless command of
momentum and super clean lines love his
work and can't wait to see what he does
in the coming year next at number nine
is Vanna Spears or aristocat Vanna has
also been a favorite for several years
now her presentation of the manipulation
style of Po spinning is really strong
and she creates really engaging and
entertaining videos in general whether
it's the fun character she creates or
the way she integrates trending music or
memes into her videos she engages with
social media in a way I find really
impressive and I think her ascendency to
poy culture ubiquity in the past two
years is a direct byproduct of that
super entertaining artist next up at
number eight is juwes Dawn or skyloop
love his flow but more than that I love
his music musicality he's one of those
artists that I always make sure to turn
on the audio for because the way he
accents the music he's flowing to never
ceases to put a smile on my face there
are few artists in the PO world right
now that I'd argue truly dance with the
prop and Jules is unquestionably one of
them love his work and can't wait to see
more of it next up at number seven is
Hector Garcia I randomly ran across one
of his videos in the explore tab on
Instagram and wound up getting sucked
into his channel for quite a while
afterwards in the past couple years I've
definitely been finding myself more and
more impressed with the speed and
precision of glow stringing and Hector's
video showcase that with a huge dose of
musicality thrown in for good measure
I'm excited every time I see a new video
of his appear in my feed super
entertaining and rounding out the bottom
five at number six is Ava fratini or ETS
I first came across her work in a video
posted to poy chat and stopped dead in
my tracks when I realized she was
performing pirouettes with her poy not
the rapid turns we frequently and
mistakenly referred to in that fashion
but real pettes after digging through
her back catalog of videos I found an
artist whose interests seem to wander
down parallel tracks of exploring
manipulation and also doing videos more
centered on dance and exploring spaces
around her like Jules she's an artist
that I find myself tuning into to see
where we can take dance as an aspect of
pois spinning and I'm excited to see
more of it in the future coming in at
number five is Antony SEMA in addition
to his really awesome work with po
Combos and explor Ing New Tricks one
thing I really appreciate about Anthony
is the attention he pays to online
education his channel po tutorial here
is consistently one of the best
resources I've seen for teaching people
po moves that fall outside the box of
what's considered the classical POI
Cannon whether it's in-depth combos
patterns or things that defy description
it's an excellent resource for those
looking to get a leg up on contemporary
poy technique next up I'm giving my
number four slot to fumi Maru Hayashi or
Hayashi Maru 7 and my goodness nobody
has impressed me with Gunslingers this
much in ages I didn't realize it until I
went to look back through the videos
that I'd saved in the past year but he
had multiple videos this year that came
out that blew me away with how smoothly
he treats his Gunslingers his fluency
with them is so developed that they feel
completely integrated into his flow
nearly every other po spinner I've ever
seen that does Gunslingers makes
entering them into a whole production
fumi marashi does his entries with such
grace and elegance that I almost don't
catch them this is what I feel like all
Gunslinger flow should look like and as
we Round the Corner into the top three I
wanted to real quickly share a few
honorable mentions in no particular
order special shout outs go to masi
VMA feel every flow AKA Kristen
Hagadorn young choic AKA sacares
Dart Bo
jugler
and vo to
stalo so let's see who landed in my top
three shall we coming in at number three
is a longtime favorite Jan Jun Yu or pom
pom Joe this guy never stops blowing me
away with his creative and outside the
box approaches to spinning he's one of
the few Spinners I've seen that creates
a sense of drama and tension around his
spinning giving us a long drawn out
setup before paying it off with a rapid
series of movements one of my favorite
videos from this year is a performance
he delivered and it's amazing to see him
doing all the things that he's so good
at live I always wonder with some high
performing po Spinners whether they're
actually as good as their video suggest
or whether they're just giving us their
best takes with this video we know for
sure he is just that good number two
swarup shett or raw flows straight up
one of my favorite po Spinners to watch
flowing in a lot of ways he almost makes
me think of older flow centered artists
like Michael paresi in that everything
he does has an unparalleled level of
fluid uidity to it everything Feels Like
It just fits naturally together like a
glove I sometimes compare transitions
between tricks as seemingly like
stacking together Lego blocks once you
realize where the transition points are
raw flow's spinning transcends even that
metaphor everything Blends together so
effortlessly that it seems like none of
his tricks were ever originally separate
they were all carved from the same piece
of marble now before I share with you my
final pick for my favorite po spinner of
2023 I have a favor to ask if you've
come this far I'm guessing you enjoy the
content that I produce so help us both
out by subscribing to the channel it
helps me reach new people and it means
that you'll know the next time I upload
a new video it's quick it's easy and we
all win thanks in advance and finally
coming in at my top slot my favorite po
spinner of 2023 is dimma rabich or izic
it's hard to know where to start with
this cat because honestly I hadn't
realized how many of his videos I'd
bookmark to revisit later whether it's
insane one-off tricks that absolutely
seem to defy the laws of physics flow
videos with beautiful movement or wild
and wonderful experiments in editing
this guy had absolutely everything I
could want in a pois spinner this year
and bonus points because he capped off
the year with a video collaboration with
katarinka or deal Lisa that is now a
personal favorite I normally avoid three
poy because it looks so painfully
asymmetrical to me but the these two put
together a fantastic snippet of
choreography using three po that well
I'll be damned if it doesn't look
Dynamite congratulations you two you
totally got me with this one well done
so there you have it those were my picks
for my favorite po Spinners of 2023 I
will leave links to the socials for all
these artists down in the description so
you can check them out for yourselves
will I do a thing like this again
honestly I have no idea this was fun for
me so let's see how the reception of
this video goes and we'll see about it
next year and finally help me discover
your favorite artists who would make
your list leave their names down in the
comments so I can check them out too
thanks for watching and have a Happy New
[Music]
Year this video would not have been
possible without my amazing supporters
on patreon in particular I want to give
a shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now if you like
the videos I create the best way to
support them is to likewise sign up to
support the work that I do on patreon
over at
patreon.com drexfactor poy everything
else I do to pay the bills from doing
private lessons to Consulting are things
that take me away from being able to
spend time creating videos like this one
so if you'd like to see more like it
please let me know by signing up thank
you so much if you'd like to see those
old top 10 videos I'll leave a link to a
playlist of them down in the description
they are still an interesting Little
slice of boy history thanks so much for
watching I hope you're flowing into the
new year and I'll see you with another
video real soon take care now peace